puis la semaine dernière nos voisins
belges peuvent travailler 4 jours par
semaine au lieu de 500 perte de salaire
en France certains patrons ont eux aussi
sauté le pas pour le plus grand plaisir
de leurs employés de jeunes enfants le
lundi je peux les amener à l'école c'est
valorisant quoi dans l'Hexagone 2/3 des
jeunes seraient favorable à cette mesure
car une semaine de seulement 4 jours
aurait effectivement quelques bénéfices
rééquilibrer la vie des salariés entre
vie professionnelle et vie personnelle
et aussi gagner en productivité mais
certains s'opposent à cette mesure comme
la première ministre Elisabeth borne je
pense qu'il faut arrêter de raconter
n'importe quoi aux Français il s'agit de
faire en quatre jours ce qu'on faisait
en 5 jours et ça peut être aussi
beaucoup de stress pour les salariés
donc on peut pas l'imposer avoir un
week-end deux trois jours impliquerait
de travailler 10 heures quotidiennement
au lieu de 8 alors certains s'inquiètent
pour les salariés au moment où on va le
payer en termes de santé au travail la
semaine de quatre jours fait débats
souhaitez-vous les weekends de trois
jours
alors
souhaitez-vous une semaine de 4 jours au
travail ou un week-end de trois jours
c'est la même question oui oui alors
vous non Béatrice j'ai failli faire un
malaise parce que j'ai vu que j'étais
d'accord avec Elisabeth borne c'est la
première fois que ça m'arrive et en fait
en théorie c'est bien en théorie on est
tous d'accord en pratique je pense que
ça va ouvrir la porte au début ça va
être du volontariat et puis petit à
petit les patrons vont peut-être imposés
des jours et puis les salaires vont
commencer à baisser je pense que c'est
c'est
le salaire il y a les 35 heures c'est
fait ça y est c'était voté Martine Aubry
si tu décides de faire 40 heures il y a
5 heures en heures sup ou alors c'est de
la récupération RTT mais si le mec te
dit par exemple un chauffeur routier le
lundi on n'a pas d'activité ça sert à
rien que tu viennes le lundi par contre
on veut que le mardi mercredi jeudi
vendredi en respectant les temps de
conduite tu le fais il faut que tout le
monde soit d'accord
si tu demandes à quelqu'un qui travaille
dans un supermarché de de bombarder
pendant quatre jours si elle te dit moi
je veux bien travailler de 7 heures à
17h quand il y a des grosses mais il
travaille déjà
sur le volant
bien sûr également dans les médias lui
préciser dans les médias il a besoin
d'être avec le besoin moi je pense que
c'est une très mauvaise idée je pense
que c'est pas du tout adapté à la
réalité d'une entreprise dans plein de
domaines on va quand même avoir des
salariés oui certaine mais quand même
qu'ils ne seront pas là presque la
moitié du temps donc ça fait encore
ralentir les dossiers ça envoie tout ça
un signal d'un pays qui au ralenti ou ça
va pas bosser ou les gens vont bosser de
moins en moins et on voit que dans les
pays où ça va mieux économiquement ça
bosse tous les jours alors pas tout le
monde tous les jours mais voilà et
ensuite on passe notre temps à dire que
les Français malheureusement n'ont pas
assez d'argent pour vivre donc ils vont
faire quoi ils vont travailler une
journée noire
ça change rien non il faut revaloriser
ça en tête parlez pas la couverture
sociale qu'on a mais ça n'a rien à voir
il faut revaloriser la valeur travail
mieux payer les salariés évidemment pour
qu'il soit plus épanouis au travail et
faire en sorte que le travail soit le
plus épanouissant possible pour un
maximum de gens on ne peut pas avoir un
pays où les gens ne bossent pas la
moitié du temps économique
chaque jour qui vont toutes les deux
minutes à la maladie à la machine à café
des magasins sont ouvert le dimanche
qu'on soit dans un pays où on travaille
le soir
alors pour vous c'est une mesure de
fainéant en résumé
que ça c'est en tout cas ça envoie le
signal qu'on est dans un pays à l'arrêt
où les gens ne vont pas bosser ou les
magasins ne vont pas être ouvert ou ça
va pas bosser le soir et je trouve que
ça ne ça ne stimule pas l'économie c'est
une mesure qui fait beaucoup à
Jean-Michel non les week-ends
définitivement changé les façons de
travailler bon mon fils travaille chez
Amazon ça fait deux ans qu'il a pas mis
les pieds chez Amazon il travaille
maintenant télétravail de chez lui à la
campagne etc ça tout bouleversé le covid
donc on va arriver
on va écouter quand même le point de vue
des des des patrons et d'un monsieur qui
est dans le bâtiment la rénovation de
bâtiments regardez
depuis que j'ai créé l'entreprise moi
c'est ce qu'on a mis en place bon après
nous dans le bâtiment c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup plus facile mais nous
pour le même pour les salariés c'est
beaucoup c'est très avantageux du fait
que ils peuvent prendre tous leurs
rendez-vous médicaux ou administratifs
le vendredi déjà soit il faut qu'il
prenne des jours de congé sinon ou RTT
est-ce que ça séduit vos candidats par
exemple quand vous faites des entretiens
actuellement là c'est ça a été ça a été
déterminant pour eux donc visiblement
depuis le covid il y a des gens veulent
travailler bien sûr t'en payer pareil et
il y a même des secteurs dans le dans le
domaine de la restauration il y a un
chef étoilé qui trouvait personne pour
son restaurant sur cinq jours il a il a
annoncé que c'était quatre jours et là
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
candidatures on a les images
parce qu'aujourd'hui le travailleur veut
c'est du temps libre j'ai reçu une
quarantaine de CV en deux jours alors
que j'ai peiné difficilement en avoir 8
ans un an voilà donc là les candidats
m'attendent devant le restaurant pour me
donner leur CV mais ils sont payés sur
quels
veulent civilités les jeunes ils veulent
travailler différemment il y a un
phénomène venu des États-Unis c'est la
grande démission les jeunes ils arrêtent
les on peut critiquer mais c'est comme
ça si vous offrez pas des solutions des
semaines de quatre jours un aménagement
du temps de travail nos jeunes ils vont
aller ailleurs ils vont partir dans les
pays étrangers qui eux sont en train de
lancer ça donc il faut Guillaume
franchement il faut ouvrir un peu les
yeux la solution c'est pas de diminuer
le temps de travail c'est de diminuer la
pénibilité au travail de valoriser le
travail alors important c'est de ne pas
dire à la nouvelle génération que
travailler c'est nul et qu'en fait ce
qui est bien c'est le travail
différemment c'est justement pour cette
raison là que certains sont cons parce
qu'effectivement il y a des domaines on
peut pas bosser 9 10 12 13 heures
mais 10 jours
au potentiel effet néfastes à cause de
journée trop denses
si vous avez une activité par exemple
avec je dirais beaucoup de mouvements et
que cette activité engage des troubles
musculus de squelettiques le fait de
l'exercer 12 heures par jour 10 heures
par jour à la place de 8h par jour va
forcément avoir des conséquences sur le
long terme mais la raison oui
je crois que Cyril est en route il est à
une minute du plateau une minute
autrement dit comme mon rôle d'animateur
s'arrête dans une ville vous assistez à
la fin de mon règne de la radio
48 heures tu peux même pas trois jours
toi
il est en moto il arrive mais j'ai
trouvé mon surnom c'est pas sera pas
l'hiver
on continue sur la semaine des quatre
jours qui pour moi a duré deux jours en
fait la semaine de découvrir un petit
peu d'avance sur le sujet ah Yannick
Jadot a toujours
on a parlé lui il a un point de vue sur
la semaine d'occasion mais j'en ai quand
même que Guillaume vous reconnaissiez
que c'est une ouverture possible pour le
monde du travail que de proposer un
aménagement du temps de travail c'est
quand même la solution ça a été la
solution pour la pour les 35 heures
c'est quand même une vraie avancée
sociale il y a certains
mais certains disent même que avec une
semaine de 4 jours on réduit on réduit
l'émission de de de carbone
effectivement on va libérer un peu les
transports en commun ça a quand même pas
mal d'avantages
ils vont moins travailler ils vont
travailler plus la semaine d'après c'est
la flexibilité
qu'on fasse des mi-temps à ce moment-là
mais c'est surtout que ça la vérité
dit la vérité voilà et c'est il y a trop
moi je conçois tout à fait qu'il y ait
trop de pénibilité au travail que les
salaires ne soient pas assez haut qui
est trop de charges sociales et que les
patrons ne puissent pas payer alors
juste valeur les salariés mais je trouve
que c'est pas bien de de d'opter pour le
cette facilité entre guillemets de moins
travailler il faut voir derrière ce que
ça engendre comme conséquence c'est
dramatique il y a quand même des
domaines il y a des domaines je crois au
Japon on travaille énormément ah oui il
y a une société qui a voilà qui est
appliqué ce principe de de d'aménagement
du temps de travail ils ont augmenté de
40 % la productivité donc c'est bien ça
dépend du salarié il y a bien un intérêt
parce que la vérité on parle souvent de
ceux qui vous qui font la pause clope la
pause café la pause machin donc si on
travaille plus efficacement peut-être
que c'est un intérêt je comprends pas
que vous êtes où ok est-ce que au lieu
de de faire l'apologie des des semaines
de 4 jours on pourrait aussi proposer
aux gens de travailler plus peut-être
qu'il y en a qui ont envie de travailler
6 jours peut-être qu'il y en a envie de
qui en ont plus envie de travailler le
soir de faire des heures sup de mieux
gagner leur vie là c'est toujours moi
toujours moi